and we are learning more about the wrong
way driving Collision from Sunday
morning it took the lives of both the
wrong way driver and a former member of
our Channel 18. and Nevada state police
reporting incidents like these have been
actually increasing on our roads and
freeways for years now Sunday's crash
was reported on the 215 Beltway south of
Town Center Drive Ryan Matthey joins us
there live now with the latest Ryan
well what we're learning from family is
that our former co-worker actually
turned the car right before this
Collision the oncoming car hit his side
and it allowed his wife the passenger of
his car to survive this crash all of
this happening in the 215 right behind
me here early Sunday morning but despite
recent technology wrong way accidents
like these keep happening
the most recent wrong way deaths from
this week 48-year-old Jose c tabates a
former 8 news now sales employee and the
wrong way driver 39-year-old quiniana
longier long Nevada state police
reporting both drivers were traveling in
the far left travel Lane headed towards
each other before colliding head-on
a wrong way problem progressing in the
wrong direction I'm very confident in
calling it an epidemic at this point NSP
Sergeant Jason barachek says in 2020
over 700 wrong away incidents recorded
the next year 40 more than before in
2022 nearly a hundred more 70 wrong way
incidents reported in just over the
first month of 2023. you don't know what
you're getting into you don't know if
you're going to have to
hit that car to disable it or if they're
going to stop for you or if you're going
to use spike strips or you just have no
idea to stop it radar technology like
this was and is being installed at
multiple freeway off-ramps signs that
flash when a wrong way driver is
detected and video sent to First
Responders 80 percent of Wrong Way
drivers reportedly turn around when they
see it but for intoxicated drivers
doesn't make a difference it usually
takes a high level of impairment for
someone to get on the freeway wrong way
so you're dealing with something that's
completely different it's just you never
know what you're going to get on a wrong
way driver call
now highway patrol is currently awaiting
that toxicology report from the wrong
way driver and at this point none of
that wrong way driving technology we
were talking about is currently along
the 215. reporting live over the 215 at
South Town Center Ryan mathie 8 News Now